[Music]
straight ahead on crime daily the
minister who officiated r kelly and
aaliyah's secret marriage testifies
against the r b singer and why do
defense attorneys for two men charge in
the murder of college student chris and
smart want the convicted wife killer
scott peterson called to testify i just
see all of this as a publicity stunt
plus five first responders indicted in
the death of elijah mclean now released
from jail on bond your look inside the
32 count indictment and later the
supreme court declines to block the
controversial texas law banning most
abortions the reactions and our legal
analysis law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin the man accused of murdering
california college student kristen smart
in 1996 wants to point the finger at
convicted murderer scott peterson law on
crime's levy is here with a strange
twist and what peterson's side has to
say
yeah brian this is all coming up in
what's been a marathon preliminary
hearing for paul flores who's accused of
killing kristin smart his father reuben
also faces charges of being an accessory
flores's lawyer wants scott peterson to
testify next week during the hearing
kristin smart vanished from the campus
of cal poly in 1996. her body has never
been found fellow student paul flores
has long been suspected of killing her
oddly enough scott peterson convicted of
killing his wife lacey and their unborn
son connor on christmas eve 2002
attended cal poly at the same time as
smart now flores's lawyer wants peterson
to testify at the hearing laura
yaretzian was on peterson's defense team
it's a publicity stunt it's a way to get
to influence potential jurors out there
that see scott peterson went to the same
school and duretzian says that's the
only connection scott peterson has to
kristin smart christian smart is not
someone that scott ever knew ever met
has any recollection of
uh has any connection to he has no
connection whatsoever
to uh what has happened here in her
disappearance a san luis obispo
sheriff's detective testified a search
of property owned by paul flores's
father ruben revealed a four foot deep
hole under the deck that contained
fibers and human blood and evidence that
a body had been there
ruben is charged with accessory to
smart's murder forensic death
investigator joseph scott morgan has
followed the case and believes the
defense bringing up scott peterson is a
distraction since investigators looked
at a possible link in the past and her
family been through enough at this point
they just are
making progress now and now
uh you know scott peterson's going to be
inserted into this i don't see this
going anywhere though
now interestingly enough laura yaretzian
says that san quentin prison officials
confirm that scott peterson has not been
served with a subpoena by flores's
lawyers and that would be necessary for
him to testify via zoom during that
hearing next week brian
thanks angenet joining us today is
criminal defense attorney mike
corobotonix and terry austin mike how
does a preliminary hearing differ from a
trial and what does the judge mean about
needing an offer of proof that
peterson's testimony is relevant
well the preliminary hearing is a much
lower level of proof much lower burden
of proof it's usually
something that's by preponderance and
evidence or clear and convincing not
like a trial where it's beyond a
reasonable doubt the other thing about a
preliminary hearing is you don't need
direct
testimony you can use hearsay you can
use when they said an offer we call it
sometimes a proffer putting forth
without the witness taking the stand
some sort of
introduction as to what he would testify
or she would testify had they taken had
they taken a stand then the judge must
decide if it would be relevant all right
now terry uh if they do that is having
peterson involved in this hearing more
smoking mirrors than substance by the
defense
it is smoke and mirrors brian there's no
question that they're doing it to make a
distraction just because scott peterson
went to the same school as christian
smart doesn't mean that he's involved
with her death but this is a common
defense tactic where you point to
someone else and who else better to
point to than a convicted person who has
been convicted of murder i also think
that the defense team is trying to claim
that the investigators did not
investigate well enough and were only
focusing on this defendant and not
focusing on other people who could have
possibly been responsible for the
disappearance and possible death
obviously of kirsten smart yeah that
makes sense as to the defense strategy
and how you pointed that out and janette
what other evidence have prosecutors
introduced at the flores hearing
well there was a detective who testified
that back in 1996
a cadaver dog was used to search the
dorm where paul flores was living and
that the cadaver dog
hit on the door of paul flores's dorm
room and the window to that room and
then there was an also some testimony
about reuben flores his father who's
charged with being an accessory a
detective said that they were seeking
some dna samples from the family earlier
this year and that reuben flores uh made
some comment to the effect of well why
are you looking for dna from these other
people in my family i'm the one who's
committed a felony and the detective
said he then went back and corrected
himself and said well i'm the only one
who's been
arrested before so
they believe that that shows some type
of consciousness of guilt on reuben
flores's part yeah interesting is that a
freudian slip or is that
him actually letting out that he's the
one that committed the crime it'll be
interesting to see how that plays out
turning now to more top legal news
britney spears will not be charged for
allegedly striking one of her employees
at her home
in the wake of her conservatorship
battle britney spears found herself
facing new allegations the pop icon
reportedly got into an altercation with
an employee that claimed spears swatted
her phone out of her hand in a statement
filed on wednesday the ventura county
d.a said that there was insufficient
evidence that a crime had occurred he
noted the lack of injury to the
housekeeper or damage to the phone
spears attorney released a statement
where he says that this accusation
should have never made it this far and
that they are glad that the da's office
has done the right thing
and in minnesota a debate is heating up
over whether cameras should be allowed
into the march 2022 trial of three of
the former officers charged in the
murder of george floyd attorneys for
thomas lane j alexander king and two tao
are asking a judge to block the
proceedings from being broadcast they
claim that due to cameras in derek
chovin's trial people are deterred from
testifying for the defense because they
fear the wrath of the crowd but
prosecutors disagree saying broadcasting
sheldon's trial ensured meaningful
public access without compromising
public health during the pandemic judge
peter cahill is presiding over the
matter and says he'll rule at a later
date
still ahead on law and crime daily the
new testimony on r kelly's secret
marriage to aaliyah but first the
indictment and investigation into the
death of elijah mclean find out what's
next after 32 charges are now filed
after the break
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true prime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate lawn crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back five first responders
indicted in the death of elijah mclean
have been released from jail on bond
following a grand jury's indictment
two police officers one former police
officer and two fire department
paramedics are facing a total of 32
charges including manslaughter and
criminal negligent homicide the charges
come on the two-year anniversary of
elijah mclean's death
stop
stop i have a right to stop you because
you're being suspicious earlier this
year an independent investigation found
there wasn't much that was done properly
when elijah mcclane was stopped and it
was also found the police investigation
into the use of force was flawed it is
important to note that neither the
caller
nor any of the officers identified a
crime that they thought mr mclean had
committed
was committing or was about to commit
police placed mclean in a neck hole that
cut off blood to his brain leaving him
unconscious and paramedics injected
mclean with 500 milligrams of ketamine a
sedative
all right just drive it right behind his
ear if he
fights all right
those paramedics are now facing
additional charges for administering
ketamine without consent he did not have
supernatural strength as you can see
from the video he is completely
restrained under a pile of law
enforcement officers each of the
defendants posted ten thousand dollar
bail and were released wednesday
colorado's attorney general said the
grand jury found their actions criminal
we're here today
because elijah mcclain is not here
and he should be
he was a son
a nephew
a brother and a friend
when he died he was only 23 years old
he had his whole life ahead
and his family and his friends just now
go on
and to the doctor
his death is a loss of all of us elijah
claims memory will live on as a blessing
to all of us
after his death colorado
continues to lead on law enforcement
accountability
back with us as criminal defense
attorney mike corobotix and terry austin
terry can you break down the indictment
for us and how much time these first
responders are facing
well as you mentioned brian there are 32
counts in this indictment all five of
the individuals involved
face the manslaughter and criminally
negligent homicide manslaughter carrying
a maximum up to six years the criminally
negligent homicide up to three but two
of the officers actually have additional
charges of assault and violence and the
paramedics as well the indictment lays
out specifically how the officers came
upon
poor elijah and pulled him by the arms
put him down on the ground and
ultimately put him in a carotid choke
hold and then the paramedics came along
and even though he was handcuffed down
on the ground in a choke hold they gave
this ketamine and they estimated that he
was 200 pounds when in fact he was only
145 pounds so
they all do face these charges we'll see
what happens but yes in fact it's a big
serious detailed indictment absolutely
now mike there was an independent
investigation made before the indictment
that will likely be a part of the trial
there they said the officers did
everything wrong in terms of a terror
stop can you explain
well you know it's interesting too terry
stopped
words were spoken by the police officer
in the clip you just showed brian where
he said i have a right to stop you
because you're suspicious
there is no articulable reason that has
been shown in any discovery that under
terry they have a right to stop someone
because they're suspicious of criminal
activity so right from the get-go his
words
spoke but his actions did not follow
this perry case which was handed down by
the supreme court in 1968.
uh it's really a very very low standard
and to be found that you didn't have a
standard to stop the person that is set
so low as in the terry case for law
enforcement presents a big problem for
these defendants absolutely i think it's
gonna be a huge problem especially with
a terry stop they have to have a
suspicion that a crime occurred not that
you're just suspicious i mean you could
be walking around with a bow tie that's
suspicious but you can't get stopped for
that right mike
well i've gotten stopped
okay
don't worry i know a good defense
attorney now to mississippi where
harrowing body cam footage shows two
police officers in a risky rescue
mission
hurricane ida's aftermath left many
towns in the south underwater flash
flooding from the severely damaging
hurricane swept away two women in their
vehicle
she's in it
luckily for these two women in
pascagoula mississippi officer collier
and sergeant murphy go right into flood
waters to help her escape from a
submerged vehicle this body cam video
captured this life-saving moment
on my shoulders
grab one on my shoulder
you still got to sleep down on here get
yourself off yeah you do get your
seatbelt off
one more
right here look
look we're on the ground right here okay
we're on the ground right here look
step with me
coming up on law and crime daily how the
supreme court's in action could change
the legal landscape on abortions rights
plus the accused arsonists on trial the
testimony from one of the survivors of
the deadly virus is read in court those
cases and more ahead
[Music]
welcome back an overnight opinion by the
u.s supreme court is causing a big
debate the decision leaves a
controversial new texas abortion law in
place
just before midnight wednesday the
supreme court issued a 5-4 order
refusing to block texas new
anti-abortion law the law allows private
citizens to sue providers who conduct
abortions if a fetal heartbeat is
detected starting at about six weeks in
an unsigned opinion the majority wrote
that the applicants have raised serious
questions regarding the
constitutionality of the texas law at
issue but their application also presets
complex and novel antecedent procedural
questions on which they have not carried
their burden chief justice john roberts
sided with the three liberal justices in
the dissent justice sotomayor called the
court's order stunning a flagrantly
unconstitutional law engineered to
prohibit women from exercising their
constitutional rights and president
biden took to twitter on thursday saying
the supreme court's ruling overnight is
an unprecedented assault on the
constitutional rights under roe v wade
complete strangers will now be empowered
to inject themselves in the most private
of health decisions the law does not
even allow exceptions in cases of rape
or incest
let's bring in criminal defense attorney
mike corbonix and terry austin to break
down the supreme court's decision mike
how did a texas court decide it would
differ so much from scotus's case roe v
wade
well you know brian sometimes people
feel and that's one of the problems with
judicial
appointments or elections of how judges
get there is it becomes political no
matter what they say it's a separate
branch of the government but the
judiciary gets influenced by politics
and sometimes people will make these
laws and hope that they will get to the
supreme court so they can actually
somehow
have some sort of credibility this is a
very unusual situation and it's
sad that it's become so political but
they have to really look at the
procedures here which are very unique in
the way you came to the supreme court
yeah now terry what are the implications
for women in texas especially those who
can't travel out of state for an
abortion now the supreme court of the
united states won't hear this case
brian you know there already are
ramifications in texas at least one
clinic has said that they are no longer
going to make abortions available if
there is any cardiac activity detected
and this has deterred many people
already they've stated and it's
intimidating patients they have people
who are outside protesting and this is
making it very difficult to provide
services and the other thing i'll say
brian
is the fact that even if you are just
driving someone to the clinic under this
texas law you can be held a liable and
not only could you be held liable but
you could have to pay money as well
crazy we'll see how this case continues
and whether or not the supreme court
will pick up this or other cases that
might combat the idea of roe v wade
thank you both when we come back the
latest on r kelly's trial the minister
who married the singer and 15 year old
aliyah takes the stand more on what he
thought of the intimate hotel ceremony
next
[Music]
welcome back a california jury will soon
be set to deliberate the fate of accused
murderer robert durst as both sides have
now rested their case
robert durst is on trial for the murder
of his best friend susan berman who was
found with a gunshot wound to her head
in her benedict canyon home in december
2000. durst is accused of killing berman
because she might have given authorities
information about durst's missing wife
kathy another murder that the realest
hit heir is accused of
after nearly three weeks on the stand
robert durst's testimony finally wrapped
up on wednesday it has been nearly four
months since the testimony resumed prior
to being paused for the pandemic closing
arguments are set to begin september 8th
and in ohio testimony is continuing for
the man accused of setting three fires
in his akron ohio neighborhood stanley
ford is charged with the murders of nine
people including an entire family and
their dog the trial started last march
but was paused due to the pandemic one
of the houses set on fire belonged to
lindell lewis and gloya gene hart two of
his neighbors the couple had people
staying in their basement the night of
the fire one of which was thomas hughley
who survived hughley's prior testimony
was read in court on thursday where he
described the night he woke up to the
house on fire if ford is convicted he
could face the death penalty
turning now to major updates in r
kelly's sex trafficking trial we're now
hearing for the first time from the man
who officiated r kelly's secret marriage
to aliyah
the door opened and outstepped aaliyah
and mr kelly those were the words of
nathan edmund the minister who married
aaliyah and r kelly a day after what
would have been their 27th anniversary
edmond testified under subpoena about
the hotel wedding between the singers
who wore sweatpants each with one leg
rolled up that only lasted 10 minutes
edmond described there only being three
other men there and that they wanted him
to sign an nda he told jurors he looked
at it read it and chuckled because it
wasn't worth the paper it was written on
neither the prosecution or defense asked
if alia looked too young to be wed the
government called dna expert young fae
wu who examined the blue shirt geronda
pace testified she saved with art kelly
seaman after her last violent encounter
with the r b singer wu said it was a
perfect match for kelly but the defense
pushed back and wu agreed that he did
not know where the sample or shirt came
from chris wilson a computer forensic
agent from the department of homeland
security testified the three devices he
analyzed two iphones and a laptop he
testified that there was a message on
christmas eve 2017 that said you're too
young and there's a lot of things you
don't know i want to groom you and bond
with you something many of the accusers
said kelly told them
mike with every witness the prosecution
seems to be closing in on every avenue
or possible avenue of reasonable doubt
do you think it's time for the defense
to change their tactic or stay the
course
i
i believe they should minimize some of
this cross-examination as a defense
attorney you know what strong evidence
against your client and if you know
you're not going to move that evidence
in your favor
it's best to stay away from it not to
highlight it again so the jury hears it
again so i think yes they need to start
gaining some more credibility by really
some of these issues allowing them to go
through you don't have to hit every
witness's testimony out of the park yeah
you've got to start realizing maybe i'm
not getting a lot of movement on this
and maybe start thinking more about
sentencing less about guilt especially
as that evidence piles in terry dna and
digital forensics
the t-shirts and texts seem to
corroborate what the accusers are
testifying to is the defense claiming
the dna expert doesn't know the facts
surrounding the blue shirt creating any
doubt
i don't think it's creating any doubt
because the forensic expert doesn't
actually need to know where it came from
he needs to know what it demonstrates as
long as we can show that
ronda pace had the shirt she wiped his
dna off she gave it to the prosecutors
yes this was back in january 2010 but if
we can show the chain of custody and the
fact that the forensic expert looked at
it he analyzed it and it was in fact
kelly's dna then i think it's just
raising some doubt but not enough
reasonable doubt i think they're solid
on that dna and the digital forensics
that's perfect some doubt but not enough
reasonable doubt terry could not have
said any better thank you both and thank
you for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
you